Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters. We're going to go over what I'm calling labs 101
Why we should run standard blood tests why it's a good idea even if
I'm out of the medical system. My doctor said they're all normal. I need to get you know deeper
It's still important to run the standard blood tests and put them into a software or talk to a practitioner who knows how to read them differently
So let's talk about that
It's really important to find a practitioner that's going to dig to find the reason why if you're not feeling well
You're you know having ill health of some kind. There's a reason
So I can't tell you through the course of 35 years of practice that
How many years?
Holy moly that how many times I've heard
People say that their doctor told them that they just need to get out of anti-depressant or they need to go to a psychologist
or it's all in their head and
That's really unfortunate because it's I'm going to show you even a recent
example of
Tom Foulery in the medical profession here in this presentation
I'm going to jump into it. Let's get some basics here first for the purpose of a functional blood
Chemistry analysis. It's really to figure out what is going on?
What is the dysfunction? Where is it? Where do we need to look further?
Where do we need to dig further and it's standard blood work and I by that I mean to standard what your medical doctor may run a
CBC in a complete metabolic panel can tell us
Give us clues and that's really what any test is whether it's
You know the gold standard pet scan and gold standard CT scan and MRI with contrast and things
They're just tests that give us clues. Nothing is going to be perfect even a biopsy is it never going to be perfect
You just you have to put all these things together and to come up with a working
Diagnosis that can change and there's comorbidities that go along with this
So what are some of the sources or causes of the dysfunction?
What specific treatments should we start with and then to retest to show that things have been restored and that we made changes
That's the purpose of this. So there's there's a lot of good reasons to do regular blood testing to see
You know, first of all things can change quickly and you want to be on top of that
It's I just spoke to somebody this morning that you know had anemia
Other blood other CBC, you know, very definite anemia on their CBC
It was done five weeks ago. Why did the oncologist order a this should have been ordered like two week into weeks after that test
So when a person has significant abnormalities on a CBC and complete metabolic panel test should be run in the least month
To look at the treatment parameters that you're doing has this person, you know, is it working or is there condition deteriorating?
And I need to be on top of it before they're in the emergency room
Run at a blood test
It's just ridiculous
Why that oncologist see that this person had irregularities in their complete metabolic panel as well as as
Anemia in their CBC panel why he didn't even order another blood test
It should have been ordered for two weeks out at least at the at the very maximum one month out to
Recheck their condition to see if they're deteriorating what we need to make some you know
Adjustments to the treatment plan he didn't even address it
But you see this all the time you see this even with functional doctors. They're not addressing it
So you have to catch dysfunctions that are easy to correct
If caught in time before it becomes an emergency room visit
Need to screen also for prescription drug related issue
So if you're on a prescription drug which many people are that can affect your blood work
And if it's affecting your blood work in a negative way you might want to
Change the prescription or talk to the prescribing doctor
Even supplements could read can have effects negatively of your blood work and we want to know those things
Now understand there's a different there's two different ways to look at your blood work
There's looking at normal reference ranges that are given by the labs
And these will often be you'll be in the normal reference range
But you'll be at the top end of the normal or the low end of the normal
The normal reference range is not something that we want to look at from a functional perspective
And I'm gonna give you an example in just a couple minutes
But the normal reference range is the average. It's not optimal
If you're at the high level of normal reference range for
you let's say
TSH for thyroid function
You know you probably have thyroid issues
We need to have an optimal range or a functional range
So we don't use standard normal reference ranges
We want to use optimal or functional medicine reference ranges
To catch things before you're in an emergency room situation
Besides normal changes from year to year it changes from lab to lab
An example of white blood cell count for one lab normal might be 4 to 10.5
Another lab uses 4.5 to 11 another lab
Which you're going to see in my example a hospital lab did it
4.5 to 13.5 or something like that which is just absolutely ridiculous
so
It just changes you don't look at normal reference ranges
You want to look at optimal reference ranges or what are called functional reference ranges
So a functional reference range is going to be much tighter
Optimal reference range is going to be much tighter. Here's an example
US labs have normal TSH that's your thyroid stimulated normal reference range of
0.45 to 4.5 some labs have it one to 5.5
Again labs have different reference ranges
And early in 2001 this is 20 some years ago
The American Association of Clinical Endocrinologist stated
Even though a TSH level between 3 and 5 is within the normal range
See their their range is different than what's given by most labs
It should still be considered suspect since it's a signal
It signals a case of evolving thyroid underactivity
So shouldn't you catch these things before they become
Way outside of the quote-unquote normal range
That's the whole idea of functional medicine. We want to catch things before they're in a complete disease state
Where it's very difficult to do anything about them at all
But it's so often that we will look at a person's labs that they were told that they were normal
And they were even not normal within the normal reference range
Just like that doctor just didn't understand it
Didn't go over it because he didn't hear she doesn't understand blood
Where I have no idea about here to be accusatory
But it's
You know why I run the test if you don't know how to interpret it
You know, I don't get it. I don't I don't know if I'll ever get it
So blood chemistry CBC analysis is a functional approach
We want to look at a functional approach an optimal approach
Not what's outside of you know pathophysiological ranges where this person's already in a very disease state
We want to look at tighter ranges in a functional approach. Okay, I think I beat that horse
So rules in looking at blood work
This is really anything you're looking at whether it's a CT scan MRI x-ray
A PET scan never rely on one test
Never rely on one test
A test is going to give you clues a test could even give you a working diagnosis
But you want to look at trends if at all possible now sure you have
Symptoms you go in and you have you know a positive CT scan for what the
What the radiologist would deem very possible cancer then you're going to biopsy and it's positive for
Let's say prostate cancer
Course we got a working diagnosis now, but you still want to look at trends. Where was this a month ago?
I don't know. I didn't get it tested. Where was it a year ago? I don't know. I didn't get it tested
Perfect example of prostate cancer. This person could have prostate cancer for five years and it stayed stable
Do we need to get super regressive in the treatment right now because now is when we found it
Well, how do we know? Well slow down look at other tests look at the trends in the
You have to compare with other objective tests and other subjective
Signs
The person has no symptoms they feel great. They have more energy than they've had in years
And now they're diagnosed with something. Yes, should you address it?
Should you look at it? Should you make some functional changes in lifestyle changes?
Well, of course those might be in the rule. Should you get aggressive in care?
I don't know you just to make those decisions
But you never rely on just one test you want to look at trends you want to look at
Multiple different types of testing when you're coming to a working diagnosis and then you want to begin a
Treatment plan that is not going to be necessarily too aggressive for the patient and then you retest
Really really important is that retesting now throughout the videos that I got to create in this series
We're going to look at all these different things. I'm not going through this with this video
I just want to show you one other example with this video a mistakes that are made in the
Medical field that we don't want to
Select by we don't want these mistakes to be made when you're looking at yourself from a functional standpoint
We'll go we'll have videos on all these different systems
In the automobile course we go through number 12 you know in great detail
These are all things that you want to look at from a functional standpoint as a functional practitioner to help these systems work better
And we'll get in detail with videos on all these different things
Here's an example of a
CBC CBC is a standard test call the complete blood count that's done
Typically if you go in for a standard
yearly physical or you go into your doctor and you're not feeling well or you went into the emergency room
This is actually a person that communicated with us a couple weeks ago
severe chest pain
I
To recommend that they go into the emergency room for the severe chest pain because there are certain tests that they could do in a lab
That they could get back immediately because most hospitals have a lab on staff and they could get an LDH at a CK test
if the person is suspected of having a
Heart attack so that they would see that there's heart damage and they need to make appropriate action
They would get an EKG. They would do
CT scan they would they have all these tools
At their fingertips that I don't have you know, so get in there and get that testing done
Well, this person went in they this is part of their just took a clip of part of their CBC
CBC complete blood count gives us white blood cell count right there atop red blood cell count
Hema globin hematocrit then it has breakdown of red blood cells and then it also has breakdown of white blood cell percentage
And I pulled up this example because
When I looked at what the hospital had sent us I was a little flabbergasted because this person ended up
Getting transported to a bigger hospital and getting
Their heart their vessels scoped and found that there was no blockage. They suspected blockage because some abnormalities on their EKG
But I just don't understand how something was missed
But let's just look at this this white blood cell code portion here
The value is 12.7. Now remember I said that reference range
Um, now different labs might say optimal range
Different labs may say reference to range like this lab and those reference ranges can vary from lab to lab
I use this example before that some labs will have a reference normal quote-unquote reference range for white blood cell
Code to 4.0 to 10.5 so we'll have it 4.5 to 11.5
Well, this lab has 4.5 to 13.5
Well, I'll tell you right now that the functional reference range for white blood cell code is really about 4.5 to 7.5
If you have a white blood cell code over 7.5 there's something going on
So this lab didn't even flag that so flag would you look at a blood test the flag means there's some abnormalities
You'll see down here the mch the mean corpuscular hemoglobin was elevated it so it's flagged as high h and then a little
elevated
Side so that's higher than the reference range. It's actually much higher than the the the optimal reference range
The white blood cell code back on top here 12.7 isn't even flagged because it's within their reference range
Again a different lab may have 4.0 to 11.0 it would have been flagged as high
So this lab didn't flag at high thereby the doctor who looked at the lab
Only is looking at those flags
So there was nothing wrong with the person. Oh, let's let's understand differential diagnosis
If the patient comes in with chest pain, what would you think of? Well, first you need to rule out heart issues, right
So remember I said there are certain blood tests that you would
Typically order right away
One would be a ck test and LTH test they didn't even run those tests. I'm like what I don't understand
Okay, then you want to do you think chest pain? Could this person is also a person that's some shortness of breath hard issues or lung infection maybe
Um, you think possibly pneumonia
Okay, maybe
Functional range of white blood cell count. I said is 4.5 ish to 7.5 ish if you have an elevated white blood cell count over
7.5 you have to think that this person has an active infection
The doctor didn't even didn't even look at that was just completely ignored
First mistake
Second thing. This is the this is the picture of the complete metabolic panel
There are some things that are elevated in this as well. I'm not gonna go over that but for the example
I just want to concentrate on that white blood cell count. So when I put this
These this data that was done at this lab into our software
We get a different picture. It's much prettier picture because it tells you in red what's abnormal
Total white blood cell count from a functional level
shows you that you're highly elevated. So the functional level that our software gives is 3.8 to 6.0
If you're at 7.5 you're above optimal range. Maybe not an infection but remember I said if you're over 7.5
You definitely have an infection. This person definitely has an infection
Completely ignored by the hospital
Because it wasn't outside of their normal ranges
Completely ignored though, but then you got to look at okay
We know this person has an infection doesn't mean that they still don't have a blockage
And you still shouldn't investigate cardiovascular issues
Which was done all of that was clear for the patient. They set the person home
Still having all the symptoms. I didn't get the lab work
Tell several days later looked at the lab and go oh my gosh you have an infection
You have elevated red white blood cells right? I don't know where they're at right now with the person
But definitely when they went into the ER that elevated white blood cells
And then you look at the how the white blood cells break down
So the white blood cells are total white blood cells total WBCs
And then white blood cells break down into separated fractions. You have neutrophils
immature gradual sites lymphocytes monocytes eosidophils basophils
So then we look at the percentage of those and we look at the absolute value. That's the real number
So both percentage and absolute value are important
But the the neutrophils are elevated
The lymphocytes are suppressed
absolute neutrophils elevated
Bato sites elevated this is a sign and we'll go over this in more detail in further labs
I just wanted to show you this lab
This is a sign that because of elevated total white blood cells this person has an infection now we go
Is it a viral infection? Is it a fungal infection?
Is it a bacterial infection?
Typically with elevated neutrophils it's going to be a bacterial infection
This person did go on
Through their doctor not through the hospital did go on and antibiotic and they went over to the hospital
Still in all this pain all this chest pain still wasn't letting up had a cough all these signs of infection
um
Never was treated for an infection in the hospital never was given an antibiotic in the hospital comes home
Goes out of the antibiotic in a couple hours their symptoms start to
Some side
Two days later their symptoms are gone
um
This is again
misseid
The functional ranges
So when you miss the functional ranges
Especially in this case which is fairly grotesque because the hospitals ranges are even
More are even wider than the that a typical labs function are normal
quote unquote range
They missed
They missed the diagnosis
Um no it was good that they tested
The arteries that there wasn't any blockage
That really put the person at ease. They thought they were having a heart attack
They scoped the arteries everything was clean didn't have to do um, you know any
Stint placement after the angiogram which that's really great
Um, that gave the person an ease as far as their anxiety
But it didn't solve the problem. They didn't dig any deeper
They didn't say why is this person having the pain better fact the doctor told him told the person that they were just having
Pluracy which isn't a disease at all which is an inflammation of the plural lighting of the lungs
Um, that's not really what they're having at all. Well, maybe they were having a pluracy
But the inflammation was due to an infection
So when you look at labs within a functional range
Instead of the quote unquote lab normal range you pick up things
That
Maybe your doctor's not picking up so when you have done a cbc in a complete metabolic panel
And you've been told that everything is normal go home
It's in your hand go to a psychiatrist and get some at the anxiety medication
Maybe they're missing the diagnosis
So this person
Serious pain thought that an elephant was standing on their chest pain
All because of an infection that was overlooked was missed because they were looking at the wrong ranges
Some of these things were even outside of their ranges so they just overlooked them
Which I found out a little fascinating
Our software also breaks down the probability of dysfunction
In this case with this person with the limited labs we had only a cbc
With the differential and a complete metabolic panel
Which still was missing several components that we would run in a cb standard, you know, wellness panel
It showed that a hundred percent likelihood of this person having an immune function
infection
Which was completely missed and the person was said told told it was normal
Um
Not good, okay? So
This software also tells you here's the immune function and explains it
And then it gives you the rationale
The right hand side there while your total WBCs total white blood cells were elevated your percent
Nutrophils were elevated your percent lymphocytes were suppressed your percent percent
monocytes were elevated your absolute monocytes were elevated and your absolute neutrophils
were elevated
And it also gives you biobarkers at the bottom in grade that we're not available in this test because the lab the hospital didn't run it
It said ferritid would have been helpful to assess a immune function
Well ferritid people think that is just an iron
Marker but actually elevated ferritid levels
Do tell us acute inflammation too, so it would have been helpful to have that that wasn't in
The test that they read
um
So
This a software also gives you the probability to function
I didn't tell you that the person also had elevated glucose levels. That's why this
Like CB is up there, but bacterial infection
Is 93% likelihood
um
Possibility of H. Pylori if they're having got issues eat also in um, but
It uh was because again you don't just rely on the blood test
This is only telling us blood tests you look at the person's subjective
findings they have pain in their chest
Um, they have short as a breath they have a cough
Um, and they had an elevated temperature for the patient
Um, these are things that need to be looked at if you're only looking at what is within the normal range given by the lab
We're going to miss things
You know, I think we're called again
Now on this we're called to study the show ourselves approved
That has to do with the word of God, but then also has to do with the things that he's given us
And he's given us this human body to take care of
So this is the intro into these labs. We're going to dig deeper into the CBC and
complete metabolic pedal so you understand the values
So you can help yourself and your family as best as possible
Uh, so stick with us and we'll make these available to everybody. Thanks